[Music]
real very excited all of it nervous
excited I can't wait what did you find
out that you were gonna do the show just
a few days ago so it's kind of yeah
that's great what about you I mean when
you really Erica was your partner she's
beautiful sexy we're gonna bring the
sexy back that's in the stars
I like that thank you
we need some of that oh wait you are
used to being on the stage and
performing in front of so many people is
different oh my gosh ballroom I have no
idea what I'm doing so I'm really in
this man's hands and he's gonna teach me
everything you know so we're gonna go up
there week after week and you know
perform and kill it good your biggest
competitor has a mountain
make sure we do a good job till he stuff
is obviously she's done this show before
Lisa Vanderpump only at least a runner
has well them they were but very kind
and wished me well and said it was the
best time of their lives and what advice
did they give to you have fun for
yourself
[Music]